if you're watching this video you're
probably thinking what are the hottest
tech gifts this holiday season well here
are our favorite picks for TV projector
and more undoubtedly one of the hottest
tech gifts this holiday season is the
SNES classic but you shouldn't get it
just because it's rare the SNES is one
of the greatest consoles of all time
thanks in part to an awesome library
there are 21 games packed into this
little thing that include Final Fantasy
6 Super Mario RPG and more many of the
titles still hold up and are worth your
time today plus it's super tiny one
emerging trend that were beginning to
see is smartphones getting rid of their
headphone jacks for whatever reason
that's why we're recommending Bluetooth
earbuds specifically we're recommending
the job of sport pace for around $50
they sound pretty good they also feature
an over-the-air design which helps keep
them snug even when you're working out
for the audiophile that might prefer
Bluetooth speakers we're recommending
the ultimate ears boom - they cost
around 150 dollars but they're arguably
the best in-class Bluetooth speakers
they can get really loud they sound
really great and they're rugged enough
to survive five foot drops and it's also
waterproof to charge all those devices
on the go you'll need a portable battery
bank that's why we're recommending Aki's
12 thousand milliamp solution it offers
enough juice to charge an iPhone over
four times over and with its two USB
ports it can quickly charge two devices
at once one great stocking stuffer this
year is Nvidia shield Android TV it can
stream your favorite apps like Netflix
and Amazon video but it can also do them
at 4k with HDR and Nabal it also
supports Google assistance so you can
ask it to give you the weather or to set
reminders finally you can also play
Android games with it and stream PC
games from locally networked pcs to your
TV speaking of TVs
tis the season of 4k HDR TVs no
seriously but kind of affordable this
year for some reason for our pick we're
going with TCL's 55 p 605 not only does
it support 4k HDR but as roku support
built-in it also cost around 600 bucks
which is pretty crazy while 55 inches
makes for a respectable size TV
it can't quite compete with the video
projector that's why we're recommending
the odd day twenty hundred lumens which
is a great budget video projector as the
name implies it offers 2800 lumens of
brightness which is bright enough for
most conditions
speaking of projectors we're gonna
project some Holograms up in here for
the hardcore Star Wars fan we're gonna
recommend Star Wars Jedi challenges
designed in partnership between Lenovo
and Disney this augmented reality
headset lets you fight villains like
Darth Maul and Darth Vader in AR plus
you'll get to look as cool as me now
where did I leave my next gift oh there
it is while high-end drones can be
really expensive DB powers you eight one
eight a fpv is a good entry-level
solution it costs around $110 for that
you get an HD 720p camera that you can
control with your phone so those are our
top picks for tech gifts this holiday
season for more holiday gift guides make
sure to head on over to gamespot.com and
thank you for watching
[Music]